they're some of the most remarkable
documents in the history of science so
when darwin's diaries went missing from
a strong room 20 years ago after being
removed for photographing there was
universal dismay with cambridge
university library concluding they'd
probably been stolen rather than
misplaced but last month as mysteriously
as they vanished the two notebooks
resurfaced in a gift bag on the library
floor
inside this printed message saying
librarian happy easter ex
there have been tears there have been
tears and i think they still will be
because we're not over the emotional
rollercoaster it means so much to us to
have these home like many other
buildings we don't have cctv in places
where people are just regularly just
passing through but our ccb monitors the
front of the building and onto the back
of the building so
we have passed the ctv that we have
available to the police and that's a
matter of their live investigation
darwin sketched his ideas about an
evolutionary tree in 1837
after a trip around the world more than
two decades before he published a more
fully developed tree of life in his
groundbreaking book on the origin of
species
i honestly think i mean the the theory
of natural selection
and evolution is probably the single
most important theory in the life and
earth environmental sciences
and this these are the notebooks in
which that theory was put together
the library says the notebooks are in
good condition and haven't been handled
much whoever took them and decided to
return them appears to have looked after
them with care
a police investigation into the
disappearance of the notebooks worth
many millions of dollars is ongoing the
mystery of darwin's diaries is anything
but an open and shut case
niv barker al jazeera